like talk to me about yourself like you
managing all this cuz mate there's a lot
going on here yeah there's a lot I mean
I'm a bit weird in the sense right that
I wanted to go into recruitment like I
didn't fall into it and and a few of my
friends take the Mout of me and say like
you're probably the only person who like
actively applied for recruitment jobs
which is funny but I wanted to do it and
I and I loved it and I and I still love
it now and I enjoy doing it welcome back
to another episode of the recruitment
mentors podcast I'm your host hea Maus
and on this week's episode I was joined
joed by Joe jany Joe is the founder of
metric search so you started recruitment
2014 with Charon Morris and then you
actually spun out metric search with
Charon Morris in uh 2019 correct as well
as that you had your best year last year
yeah yeah doing 950 whilst growing this
business yeah try trying not to go red
in this episode we really delve deep
into how Joe has gone about going from a
top performing individual contributor to
Leading a business how they've
approached expanding their US market how
he's really been dedicated to building a
culture of Business Development and high
performance there's going to be so many
takeaways in this conversation all of
you who are in the trenches right now of
growing and building your own
recruitment business what are Joe's
principles when it comes to increasing
the client spend this is something that
I developed since moving to mattre enjoy
this week's
episode Joe welcome to the podcast thank
you JM thanks for having me
excited yeah looking forward to this uh
really enjoyed getting to know you the
business Journey that you've been on and
uh yeah I think a lot of people um are
going to be able to learn a lot from
this journey that you're in and and that
you've been on so far so I think today
uh we're going to try and cover two sort
of aspects one Joe's approach to
Recruitment and how he's maintained his
performance levels despite growing a
business last year was your best year
even though the business was at the
biggest point so I think people going
want to know how how Joe goes about his
business and the things that you live by
your principles but then two we're then
obviously going to make sure that we
talk about this entrepreneurial Journey
that you've been on um and you know
you've been building this business
metric search over the last four years
um so there's going to be loads of stuff
that we can learn from you on there so
just to give everyone the career
highlight will uh from um Joe highlight
will so I'm going to go through this if
there's anything that I've missed thank
you okay so we got uh so cool so you
started recruitment
2014 um with Charon Morris and then you
know progress your career there and then
um the you actually spun out metric
search with Charon Morris in 2019
correct but then you sort of outgrown uh
Charon Morrison you're are now the
majority shareholder which was
officially done at the start of 2022 but
the business Milestones have been
starting in 2019 in the first year um
you did $1.8 million in Revenue we're
doing dollars because Joe does a lot in
the the American Market eight or9 people
in the first year uh year two5 million
um dollar uh 22 uh people year three $10
million 45 to 50 people and then year
four um which you've just uh finished
you finished just under 12.7 million do
in revenue and that was 27% growth on
last year's revenue and you also grew
the GP by 30% as well and you're around
60 62 people um as well as that you had
your best year last year yeah yeah doing
950 Grand in one year that was your your
best year um whilst growing this
business yeah try I'm trying not to go
red so we're gonna unpack this because I
think there's tons that we can learn but
let's start with the million pound
question I'd love to hear your take on
what you believe are the common
characteristics and traits of a highly
successful recruiting in today's market
yeah thank you and um thanks for the
introduction much appreciated um
obviously changed a lot over the last
few years I think for me the the key
attributes that that we're looking for
and when I think about the top pillars
here right now it's coachability is a
huge one wanting to con L improve
yourself and
self-development and the BD skills and I
guess we're going to get onto this later
the BD skills have just come to the
front so much this year um so
coachability self-development and then
real hunger and drive to do BD um
they're the three things that for me
makes someone a world class
recruiter love that so let let's just
give people a bit more context and I
just want to make sure that we're
entirely on the same page here so have
you so you um yourself you've always
done the life science Market correct
yeah always worked in the cdmo space of
life science which is a a niche sector
but um yeah always worked that space
myself it's always been per always perm
all perm and then what when did you
start doing it in America and is like
the majority of your personal like
performance being in America or not so I
think the first two years of my career I
did Europe um when I was working at Char
Morris in leag s um I think did 300K
first year and then
525 year two and then I asked them to
move to the US and be their general
manager which they supported me to do
and from there we kind of built like a
little New York incubator team I think
four of us went out originally um and we
were working the US market from leads um
2018 and then moved over there then
so9 which is then when we started metric
yeah so um so been doing the US market
since
then okay so okay cool so since then
you've solely been in the American
market and then is that what the large
chunk of your uh team in the UK do the
US Mark yeah so so in metric 85% of our
revenue is in the US and that's across
our offices in London Nottingham and
then obviously U New York and Florida so
we're very very us
heavy yeah okay cool that I'm glad I
understood that then and then obviously
final bit you obviously your track
record is life sciences but then you
also part have a literally 50/50 which
was telling me yesterday is also then
correct yeah engineering and
infrastructure is is again 50% of our
Revenue now which is an area I don't
know loads about but we hired some great
people who know those markets inside out
and they're very similar fees sizewise
to life science and process-wise um but
just completely different
functions okay so let let's just start
with like the recruitment stuff and then
and then let's go into like Joe the
business owner because I'm sure that's
continued to evolve like I've got an
upto-date view of like what your or
chart looks like and what your
day-to-day role is like now but like you
wouldn't have got to this point without
being great at recruitment um and
obviously you're still very much
performing now so why don't we just
start cuz I know this is something that
you really drove in your business and I
think something that you believe is one
of the main reasons why you was able to
grow um or continue to grow in the
fourth year year cuz you double down on
building this sales culture this
business development culture so I'd love
to just hear your take you know with
where you are now because I'm sure this
is evoled over time what would you say
are like how how can a perm recruiter
become worldclass at Business
Development like let let's just start
there like what are the the core
principles to becoming world class at
business devel yeah good good question
and I guess that's the one that that
everyone's asking themselves at the
minute right now the fish on aren't
jumping in the boat as much like you
have to go out and hunt for this
business so so for me you've got to want
to do it first of all right you've got
to want to pick up the phone you've got
to want to send those emails and and
again a part of Business Development
that goes under under the radar is
actually getting the clients on the
phone and that's got a lot harder so I
think nowadays you've got to have a
great personal brand um as a lot of
people I see posting on LinkedIn and
it's something we're working on here at
metric but making those cold calls
slightly warm for me is massive now when
you when they're seeing you content
you're engaging with them on LinkedIn
and
socials that is at least going to help
you get your foot in the door um
obviously when you get on the phone with
them impressing them is a completely
different matter but but for me it's
being candidate LED and it's not being
afraid of that and having a great
candidate to get in front of the it's
got so competitive recently right that
these recruiters are talking to clients
all the time like you've got to have a
good candidate to back up what you're
saying it's all well and good me going
on the call and saying look I'm the
number one recruiter in the cdmo space
this is my track record generally they
just want to see a great candidate they
want to see a solution so it's very
basic I did a training session
internally with that at metric very
recently which has gone down really well
where I was like look if we're not
getting anywhere we're not getting them
on the phone we're not getting calls
booked in like let's go with the
candidate approach it works we've got
great people who are going to add value
to these businesses whether that's like
science or whether that's engineering if
they're going to make you 50 million
more Revenue a year or they're going to
save you 50 million a year we need to be
calling them and pitching those
candidates in and again that's old
school right um but that is a massive
factor for me in
BD probably more importantly now again
really basic but just actually doing
what you say you're going to do so we'll
get we'll get on a client call and I'll
say look I'm going to have you a short
list within 3 days they're all going to
be relevant comp candidates and and I I
encourage the Consultants here to put
themselves under a bit of pressure say
you're going to have a short list in 3
days and make sure you've got one and
that's how you set yourself aside from
everyone else who's calling and pitching
these clients at the minute so probably
two really basic fundamentals but for me
they work they're tried they're tested
they're never going to get a client's
never going to get bored of seeing a
worldclass resume that's going to add 50
million to their business um but make
they have to see it right
so let let's just break down that first
bit if if you don't mind because I think
this is something that I used to do we
all do but I think it's about what
you're talking about here is doing it
consistently and doing it really well
what I've picked up on there is you're
saying you know it's candidate LED but
you're then leading with what problems
that candidate can solve for the client
right so that's something I picked up on
that I don't think everyone will be
doing that you know this person's got
this skill Joe so you need to be you
know interviewing them but you're saying
hey I've got this person and they can
you know you know you told me about this
about your business or they could save
you this or help you earn more money I
think that that's that's definitely
something that not everyone will be
doing so you know especially if you've
done a training uh session on this
recently give us some details like what
what does good look like what does a
good candidate Le approach look like
what are we you know are we calling and
what we saying about this candidate are
we emailing them what we putting in the
email like just talk give us some of
those cuz I think that that's what
people are going to want to know and
hear how people approach yeah and and I
guess I'll use life science as an
example which is which is closer to me
so at the minute life science Market's
tough right I'm sure you've had plenty
of people come on the podcast tell you
how hard life science recruitment is
right now um so when the market gets
tough what do people need they need good
sales people so you get the BD directors
right you get the best ones in the
market ideally we're getting on the
phone with the client and pitching them
in right so I'm I'm calling them saying
look three of you competitors are
interviewing this BD candidate they're
the best person on the market they're
the number one person in California the
revenue they've done in the last three
years is 10 million 20 million 30
million can you really afford to let
them join your biggest competitor surely
it's worth you speaking to
them I don't understand how anyone would
ever say no to that right there I mean
say look they're interviewing me fre Bo
competitors they want to join you
they're actively looking they're going
to be gone in two weeks like at least
have a trap with them and your door
opener so first first ideal situation is
you call the chief commercial officer or
CEO and say this is this is what we have
if they don't so that that's that's the
pitch what you just said that that's so
if I say if I call you and I've got that
candidate I'm going Hey Joe um look
working with this person at the moment
they're actually interviewing at your
three best competitors this is their
track record um do you think you can
afford not to see them or for them to
join your competitor is that open
basically yeah why not it's a bit it's a
bit aggressive but but that is basically
it you name the companies you tell them
who we work with currently um who were
also their competitors and it's like d
you need to be working with us as well
and that's the same on the life science
side and the engineering side as well
right the the demand for talent is great
in both of those spaces so um that's the
approach and then again if you can't if
you can't get them on the phone it's a
version of that via Rema and say look I
tried to call you about this
earlier this is what we've got can we
have a quick chat to discuss like
there's nothing to lose you don't have
to pay to speak to this candidate and
and this approach is something that
we've we adopted this year right don't
get me wrong the year we year three for
us when we went from 5 mil to 10 mil we
didn't need to do this but this year
when we've gone from 10 mil to 12 and a
half mil that aggressive approach and
more proactive approach is what has
allowed us to grow 27% yeah yeah so Ju
Just I know you're getting graned here
but this is what's helped ful for people
so just so on the email like you trying
to say it the same way or you just like
super like just bullet points Hey Joe
work with this person at the moment
they're intering your competitors is it
a bad idea for you to also meet them
rather than them join your competitors
like is it just is it very similar what
you're say yeah but with more detail so
then V Remo you can put a bit more in
right so you're selling the the products
or Services they're selling the revenue
they've generated and where where where
they are and the the territory they they
working and and generally in life
science like if you've got someone in
Boston or California like that
candidate's God dust um so people are
going to want to speak to him it's hard
to get good people in Boston it's hard
to get good people in California so it's
a version of that with a little bit more
detail around the products and services
and and obviously right this this I'm
talking about you have to be sending a
good candidate if you ring them up and
if you ring them up like I've got this
person they're amazing they're doing 50
mil like they they're working for a
direct competitor and then you send
someone over who's just completely
irrelevant or not good they're going to
be what are you doing and it's almost
like this approach is you putting your
neck on the line and I sometimes I will
I will say this still myself like look
trust me on this one if this one's not
good then then you don't have to work
with me ever again but if they're good
then we'll we'll start a partnership so
again when I say it starts with a good
candidate it does but they're out there
and you can find them and you build
relationships with them and and for me
this is just like recruitment 101 right
like this stuff will never get old yeah
yeah no yeah Fair no absolutely so and
then just technical one CU I think
people will be interested what are you
what have you found to be the most
effective tool of getting numbers in the
American market for you have you
invested anything that helps you get
numbers because that's going to be key
to this approach you need
dat yeah cuz that's pretty spend is it
but like I've heard that's consistent
for the US market yeah cuz you need
numbers otherwise you're not going to be
to do this or and that Zoom info is the
one for me like we've I've tried a few
looked few of Zoom info is the
best yeah for the American Market you
found well obviously that's you might
get you might get to sponsor the podcast
now maybe I know they do a lot in the
for in the recruitment industry So Okay
cool so that's been fundamental like I
appreciate you sharing that I guess I
was going to say I was going to say to
you like where did this is recruitment
101 but where do people always go wrong
with this and it sounds like doing that
approach with a average candidate like
you have to have a really high standard
it seems on cuz like that's your rep
you're building your reputation there so
you could ruin that reputation or you
know build it yeah the candidate has got
to be good and I guess where I guess
where people go wrong with this it's
just people don't don't want to try and
do that because it's hard and it is a
little bit
forward and I guess some of the
recruiters who started when the life
science Market in particular was booming
they never really needed to do it so you
could kind of get you could do fees just
via email at that point where you just
sending series and they're getting hired
but um I guess it's getting out your
comfort zone and the reason it falls
down is people didn't need to do it and
now they do so it's a but I didn't used
to do this and I built 300K last year I
didn't I I've been doing fine without
doing this and it's like yeah yeah you
have but we want you to be doing 5 600k
bilings a year and this is how you get
there and this is how you take it to the
next level so I guess it's just
overcoming it potentially being awkward
other than potentially saying why would
I want to interview someone who all my
competitors are speaking to which they
could say so um but it's like anything
right any sales job like you're going to
get nose and you're going to get
awkwardness but um but everyone I can
honestly say everyone who's adopted it
here at metric has had like immediate
results from it so um we'll again it's
something else we'll be like doubling
down on this year and and moving forward
continue yeah and then and then just
curious then from a management
perspective leader perspective how do
you quality control
that process because you know we all
hear our recruiters they just you could
quite easily just have loads of people
just pitching rubbish at people and
that's you know one of the quickest way
to ruin your reputation so how how do
you quality control that process cuz
yeah yeah yeah I mean that's where it
that's where it falls down right if the
quality is not there I mean we've got 17
managers who who most of like our
average biller here does 400k as I guess
as we talked about today so the manag
are all 5 600k billers they are not
going to let their reputations get
ruined by someone going and pitching the
wrong candidate to the wrong client so
they are on top of that and everyone's
and I am saying to them when I do this
training I'm like this has got to be
your best candidate like this is your
number one you do this for for the best
person this isn't a oh I'll try force a
interview with someone who's a five out
of 10 this is like this is for you 10
out of 10 candidates so the manager
quality control that and and everyone is
generally invested in making metric a
very successful brand in both our
markets we work in so um I guess that's
how with quality controlled it and touch
wood we've not had any issues with that
so
far and then and then just on the flip
side I know we're focusing on this but
like this like you said this first
because it's clearly having an impact
and a positive one so how do you what's
the pitch on the flip side so if I'm a
candidate of yours I know I'm [__] hot I
know that I can add a lot of value like
why am I going to give give you the
opportunity to sell me and Pitch me into
these companies why am I going to trust
you to do that that's my reputation uh
so what what on the flip side what what
does that look like because you have to
also be good at that not only get these
people and have these people but they
have to trust you that Joe is going to
call these people people in their
industry that they obviously no doubt
want to have a good reputation with to
pitch me in of course so what does that
look like on the I guess first of all
they've got to be looking right again
you you can't be doing this with someone
who's not looking for a new job because
you're wasting their time and your time
but again firstly you make sure they're
looking and then thankfully metric we've
got a track record where we work with
some amazing clients we work with great
startups we work with Market leading
Pharma companies we've got blue chips so
we can talk them through the clients
we're already working with so they're
already going to those so we're already
getting them valuable interviews with
with household names in these markets so
they're bought into us anyway and then
from there we're like look we're going
to try open a couple more doors for you
the criteria of your search is XY Z this
company might be perfect for you as well
so I'm going to get you in with them um
that's it really it's again it's
recruitment is all about credibility
right and if you've got good clients and
you've got good candidates which which
we have and everyone has um it's about
making that work for you um and if you
go to speak to these kind and say look
these are our top five clients in the
farm space from last year um they're
going to be impressed by that and we're
going to get them introduced to them and
then say look we're going to get you a
couple more as well and then and again
why would you say no to that so we're
going to get you in with five great
companies I'm going to try to find five
more like no one's going to say no to
that if they're actually looking for a
drop nice so let's build on this then
you had your best year last year and you
shared with me that in order for you to
do that 950 90% of it was retained and
it was of 11 clients and average deal
size was around 4050 so when I sort of
ask you like what you think your
colleagues would say you're world class
at uh one is obviously the client side
but also then you spoke about long-term
agreements increasing the lifetime value
of the clients that you work with how
much money they spend with you you know
taking people that do one or two
searches with you to be doing four five
10 and more talk to us about again same
question I guess but with that in mind
what what what are Joe's principles when
it comes to increasing the client spend
like you know building long-term
agreements where these companies are
spending you know half a million with
you rather than 100 Grand yeah and this
is something that i' developed since
moving to metric when I first started
recruitment I was really shortterm and
thinking shortterm and thinking High fee
percentage when I founded metric I was
like when this is going to be a business
built on Partnerships and long-term
relationships and and I'm pleased to say
like a lot of our top I think all of our
top clients have been with us pretty
much since the start so look everything
starts with delivering a great service
there's there's nothing you can get away
with that and I say just actually
delivering what you say you're going to
do is number one if you don't if you
don't do that you're not getting past
deal number One never mind deal number
50 so doing what you're saying going to
do delivering candidates fast and with
detail is key but where I have been
really good in in in terms of developing
these longer term relationships it's I
am quite open with them and say look and
again I don't mind showing this with you
so like a lot of these relationships we
start working at
25% and I'll say look why don't you just
give me all of your roles director and
above we'll still do them retained but
I'll reduce The Upfront retainer payment
and we'll just do them at 20% and you're
going to get the world class service
from me that you've been getting at 25%
B at 20 but I want all your roles for it
again they're looking at that thinking
right well I'm going to save I'm to save
big money here and and that's what I've
done with probably our top clients and
that's enabled us to double what we've
been doing with them year on year so
that again seems quite basic but I'll go
meet him and say look I've got an idea
it's going to save you money it's going
to enable us to work together more and
then I'll just reduce the fee percentage
but say look it's got to stay retained
if you want to work with me because I'm
strapped for time running four officers
and 60 people so it's got to be retained
um and that's how we've done it it's
again really straightforward like lower
the fee percentage over time and ask ask
for all the roles and and again like one
of one of my principles is like every
time I speak to a client I ask him for
more roles and that again just sounds so
basic but I think it's actually yeah you
got to ask every time and like I want
them to say to me Joe like you ask me
this every time like I'll let you know
when they're coming then I'm like right
good at least they know I'm available to
work on them and that's why I'm trying
to drill into everyone at metric just be
like let them know you want the roles
let them know you're enthusiastic about
the roles let them know that you want to
fill them and you've got time to fill
them and people want to work with
enthusiastic recruiters who like working
with them so say hey I love working with
you can anything else we can work on
this R is in a great position can you
give me something else and then all of a
sudden you've got 10 roles and then you
talk about lowering the fee percentage
and again that I feel like a lot of the
stuff I'm telling you is really basic um
and really straightforward and is
interest yeah but it's good to on it's
good to hear that though because we can
over complicate things and you can hear
the same thing over and over again again
doesn't necessarily mean that you're
going to do it and you take it on do you
know what I mean so like I was going to
I was thinking from your experience when
when is like the perfect time to ask
that is it like as soon as you've you've
you've done that first placement where
you've you've shown what you can deliver
the first question you're asking after
they've started or whatever you're like
hey as you can see did a great job here
what else can we do like what when have
you found to be the perfect time to ask
it honestly when when you've got an
offer out when they've made the offer to
the
candidate again things can go wrong we
all know that not everything gets
accepted I'll be like look this is in a
good place cand is probably going to
accept whilst you guys are closing this
out and we're closing it out let's get
started on something
else so I would do it just when the
offers
out when the offers out yeah yeah yeah
that's everyone a Friday it's a Friday
the offer's out it's going to get
accepted anything else we can go
for has that been so that approach then
has that been um because have you like
try manag to culate quite a lot of
cross- selling or people doing that and
then pulling roles in other niches in
the life science team or is that how
that's work generally yeah generally and
and like I say once you've done a good
job on something and you've got an offer
out of course they're going to give you
the next role and and that's how again
that's how you get big accounts and you
keep working with them and you're not
having to do loads of
BD constantly bringing on new clients
because if you're get new roles in new
functions and and one of the best things
about metric is that it is really
collaborative and I know everyone
probably comes on the podcast and says
this but touch word again we don't have
arguments over split fees and there's no
like that's my client this that's my
client it's very much everyone's working
together and like like you say if
everyone has that approach and everyone
pulls rolls and you cross cell and you
hey can you help this is probably better
for you but and again this will get
harder as we go over a 100 people like
we're only 62 right now and hopefully
people will listen to this and and keep
doing it but that's been great for us
and I think that makes the culture what
it is that hopefully everyone's got
roles to work on that have been passed
by someone else um and I feel quite
passionately that that we keep that in
place curious if I'm someone that wants
to consistently build 400 500 Grand I'm
earning really good money like they're
my aspirations I might think you know
what if I get to that point why can't I
do a million but if we're saying like we
want to get to 400 500 Grand how many
clients do you reckon I need four 500
Grand probably depends which Market I
reckon you can do that with five I re
you could do 400k with five
clients five clients yeah it's just
interesting to hear because I think
again this is something we're talking
about getting the most out of the
relationships that you have often people
think the only way I'm going to get
there is by adding another 20 clients
but it's not necessarily the case harder
isn't it it's so much harder to go and
find a new client sort terms with them
then you have to see if they're actually
going to be serious about hiring people
by the time you've done all of that like
you probably could have filled two other
roles with someone who is who is a
serious client who's who's making offers
who's moving fast who wants their best
talent so um yeah I think five five good
clients you'll you'll do four 500k this
podcast is proudly partnered with vin
Cherry the all-in-one recruitment agency
software that over 20,000 recruiters
trust daily we're also partnered with
the award-winning oneup sales the sales
and motivation platform that enables you
to maximize the potential of your teams
we love partnering with both of these
organizations because they share our
mission in helping you get the most out
of your people and your business you can
get exclusive offers because you listen
to this podcast and get up to 10% of the
usage price forever use a link in the
show notes to get your hands on that
let's get back to the
episode so I want to definitely get your
perspective on on the US like your
experience in building this business in
in the US and doing a lot there but just
very quickly I think people are going to
you know be dying to
know 950 running a business like how do
you manage your time like CU you you
surely must be pretty string like really
disciplined with what you say no to what
you say yes to like how you like how
have you structured your day to make
sure that to perform at that level
whilst also managing your managers
leading by the front all the other stuff
that comes with running a business so
like talk us through like what does a
normal day for you look like what what
are the non-negotiables yeah good
question so like I will try now I'm back
in in the UK I will try to get all my
like admin and management stuff when did
you come back sorry it's to botom when
did you come back to the UK uh end of
cool yeah so let's talk about from the
UK then from the UK like all my admin
management stuff in the morning like
meetings in the morning then soon as it
gets to one well as soon as it gets to
12 like on the phone with the US doing
that but again and this is I don't know
how popular or not this is to say but
like I just work 24/7 like I'm at home
I'll be working I'll be available 24/7 I
went to Marb last week and my M was like
are you actually going to have some
holiday have trying to interview people
I'm trying to Sol two retainers on
holiday so again like not I don't expect
everyone to to want to do that or to try
and do that but but again I will make
decisions fast and as soon as something
high priority comes into my inbox it
comes I deal with it straight away and
that allows me to do that and then being
ruthless from a billing perspective with
clients that you're working with and
that's why I'll say look if you want my
time it has to be retained now because
because I'm really busy if you don't
want to wear retain that's fine I'll
give give it to someone on the team no
no drama because someone else can fill
it um and that's helped and again like
having repeat business is has been good
and and me transitioning from being the
top biller at Char Morris to being the
managing director of metric was like
stopped one on Friday start one on
Monday and picked up with all my new all
my clients so there's never been that
break for me like I've just consistently
build from when I started in 2014 like
all the way to now so I'm just in a
routine and good habits with it and I'm
ready to te my clients it's I've never
had that period where it's like right
got to build everything back up again
here because because of the nature of
the way we spun the business out which
is how we did 1.8 year W it was just
like
continuation um yeah so talk when you
talk B at Char Morris give us your day
plan bro what what did that look like a
long time ago it was a long time ago now
surely there must be some structure in
there besides like just being committed
to like doing whatever comes in taking
action was you like right I'm always
going to make sure I always have two
hours of BD at this point like you might
not I'm just just curious on like how
you prioritize your time genuinely like
I've never been a
massive structure person and I've never
been massively like I used to write a
DAT plan and then it just go straight
out the window it's always just been
focused on on numbers for me and I'll be
like I have to do 16 interviews I range
16 first stage interviews every month
and I'll be like I need to do
minimum so so my Golden Rule at metric
and everyone's probably bored to death
of me saying this is like you have to
have 100K of Pipeline on your business
sheet at all times like that's the
minimum why because how you're never
going to do 100K month if you don't have
100K on your pipeline but
generally if you've got 100K worst case
you're going to do
30 so so again like that's so my
principle is you say how do I manage my
time like I'll just make sure I've got
20 100 200k on my business sheet at all
times and I'll do whatever I need to do
to get that rather so so what what does
a business sheet mean like what what
does what does that mean pipel I guess
so like in what would you deem as
pipeline second second stage interviews
and onwards for for serious RS so have
at least so have at least 100 so for
your team minimum 100 Grand worth of uh
potential fees that are at Second Stage
or more minimum
minimum and like we really celebrate
people doing 100K month here like that's
a big achievement metric if you do 100K
month you make 40K commission right so
that's like I want yeah the commission
is good and and and it's high reward and
so I'm trying to teach everyone how to
do 100K a month as frequently as
possible and the answer to that is so
what's your equation then you said 16 F
so like because I think that's what
would be interested to people I get what
you like I know my numbers I know the
key metrics I need to do so it's more
about like knowing those and then doing
whatever you can to get to those because
it should lead to X outcome so you said
16 first stage interviews what are the
other like numbers on your like golden
dashboards that would be yeah yeah so so
16 first stage interviews is is like
absolutely key five vacancies otherwise
you you never get in 16 sendouts or 16
interviews arranged um and generally
that for me that is it and then 100K on
your pipeline it's really simple it's
not I'm not saying to people you have to
send 50 CVS or I'm not saying you have
to make a 100 calls I'm saying look just
hit your 16 just hit your 60 send outs
and have 100K on your pipeline you're
fine um I say send outs send outs as
interviews um but yeah that's it so 16
first aage interviews probably with
fight you want at least that with across
five different different clients that
should equal uh healthy pipeline 100K
months yeah and and that and for me it's
that simple and and the stats show at
metric if you hit in 16 first stage
interviews
consistently over a two to three month
period you will do 100K Revenue month in
the in the months
following um so again really basic what
what are your like key performance
metrics in terms of like what do you
work to on like interview placement
ratio like those sorts of things I'm
sure you're on that then if if that's
how you think that what do you always
want those to be around or what you
aiming for those to always be around it
changes so much and and to be honest
like we don't track that massively
because at the minute with the brands
all being under metric life science and
engineering is slightly different
they're slightly different in that sense
so generally one in three candidates
will get an offer who are interviewing
on the engineering
side in life sciences probably more like
one in 12 get an
offer um the engineering side is more
candidate driven than life science at
the minute um but as I guess as we
touched on like when we split the brands
into two brands in the future like I'll
I'll look at that a little bit more to
be honest because they they and again
this is why we're doing it because the
they are slightly different in terms of
the approach needed you kind of have the
exact same expectations and different
approach yeah so so let's go do just
curious on a couple of the US things
then how have you I think definitely
leaders will be thinking just firstly
there's there's a lot of people here a
lot of them in the UK cuz correct me if
I'm wrong you got someone starting on
the ground in Florida yeah someone
moving from New York to open Florida
yeah and then you've got your New York
office so how have you approached the
like doing the US market from the UK
like what what's what are the hours
firstly how have you approached that
yeah so it's interesting because we did
this in Reverse so because I launched
the business in New York obviously I'm
English but then as being there first
gave us a massive Advantage because
we're already there we're a US business
we're metric Inc before we were metric
limited so that's been huge but in the
UK we have they work UK hours um so what
does that mean I think they do 83 till
six yeah and so you don't do the like
like 11 to 7 or something like no I wish
we did but it's probably too late to
change it now but um really but no it's
fine it's not been a problem and
everyone else I know who works the US
market from the UK work Works those
Works those hours but are are the
expectations though if you have
important [__] coming at 8 9:00 they're
probably going to do it is is that the
expectation yeah like certainly but why
would why would you not right the the
the commission goes up to
60% here and
and that is the expectation but for me I
would always rather work the US market
than the UK Market because it's bigger
feas it's fast to turn around you get
way more respect from ta you get way
more respect from the
candidates the UK is tough now and the F
percentage is a low
so and and I will tell them this that
that the US market is is the place to be
at the minute whether you're in the UK
or the US um but yeah they still they
still work UK hours but but is the
expectation I know sometimes business
owners I've spoken to have like been a
bit worried about that not sure but you
think per clearly it's it's you're
clearly capable to do what you need to
do in those hours yeah but there's
probably going to the expectations to be
but as you know stuff will be happening
late in the evening and you will likely
have to do things um out of half course
yeah and look not everyone wants to do
that and that's
fine but then recruitment uh metric
probably just isn't the job for you and
that's fine yeah yeah okay so curious to
get your thoughts then if Joe was to
start the US market from scratch first
90 days what would they look like for
you everything that you know how would
you approach the first 90 days of
building let's say you didn't spun out
of you know Char Morris you're out of
covenants you're ready to go first 90
days what are we doing that you think is
going to give you the the quickest route
to am I in notore or am I in New
York whatever could be I'd say Let's do
let's do UK UK so first thing I'm doing
is is LinkedIn post right I'm moving
over to New York so excited to set this
business up please give me all your all
your New York recommendations that's the
that's the first thing I'm doing and
saying then you're getting the best
pizza spot best steakhouse what very
easy so that's going to run in the
background then I'm going and calling
and messaging and email emailing every
single person I've ever worked with or
ever met or ever talked to and said hey
exciting news guess who's moving to New
York can we have a call ahead of me
moving over I'm really excited to hit
the ground running um we've always had a
great working relationship um let's have
a chat and I'm just filling my diary for
90 days with calls of candidates of
clients and then anyone I've worked with
in Europe it's saying hey look good news
I know you'll support me I'm moving to
New York really exciting move for me and
my family can you put me in touch with
your us counterparts and I'm just
speaking to every and I'm letting every
man of his dog know for 90 days that I'm
coming to New York to set up um and it's
that's all that's all I'm going to do
for 90 days and I'm going to get
vacancies and I'm going to get send outs
and I'm going from there and again
sounds really basic
but and I found this myself personally
do you know when I actually did move to
New York I can't believe how helpful
everyone was all my clients all my
candidates they just wanted to support
they were like I'm so happy for you I'm
so excited for you this is a massive
move I was only 25 when I moved out
there right and they couldn't have been
any more supportive and they recommended
me to other clients and they're like hey
this guy Joe's coming he's good he's
done a great job for us I'm going to put
you in touch with um some of my other
sea level contacts and then it really
just snowboard from there um so if
you've got good genuine relationships
even if they're not people in the US
like they'll introduce you to people in
the
and and they and Americans they want to
help they love people they love
entrepreneurs they love people setting
up their own businesses like they want
them to do well probably more than I
find British people
definitely yeah well British people are
great at building people up and then
when they're too successful they would
just want to see yeah yeah yeah they're
like they think you're getting too big
for your boots but in the US there's
none of that they want they want you to
succeed and that is and I love that and
love working with them and if I was to
start this
again that's what I'd do I just and if I
was a what what states would you pick to
focus on good question
so New York is in probably my it's
probably my favorite city in the US like
I love it love living there it's
probably the hardest place to like scale
a business in the US why expensive um
expensive um no it's expensive and the
markets that we do aren't really New
York markets to be totally honest with
you like life is more finance and
business services in New York right it's
less there's obviously a bit of
construction but if I was to pick States
I'd pick Florida obviously we've just
picked it I'd pick Texas um we're
looking at doing California and we're
going to open that in the next few years
we we did 80 placements in California
and like close to two million Revenue
there last year so there's a business
case for us to be in
California but I'd probably be looking
at Austin I'd be looking at Miami we're
going to Fort
Lauderdale um I think that's where I
would be looking just given the
migration of people from the major hubs
South um yeah so I think that's probably
if I was to start again that's if you
was if he was doing it in the UK how
often would you try and get over to the
US because I feel like whenever I spoken
to people they've seen real it's like
been really positive for them to have
people on the ground and they've seen
like great things from that but yeah I
spoke to quite a few people that have
made sure that they've gone over there
maybe once a quarter I don't know how
would you approach that would you try
and go over there consistently do you
think that's important yeah I'd say I'd
say it's like if you if you were the
business owner you want to be over there
quarterly quarterly if you're if you're
a recruitment consultant you want to be
at minimum one conference in your Market
over there ideally too um but obviously
people want to see Roi on that but yeah
of course that's super interesting okay
um thanks for Shar all that I know like
I'm sure you I'm sure you've recognized
that more and more UK firms are you know
going into the US wanting to do more
like that that way more of that has
happened over the last two years 100%
And and for me the key is you got to
have something over there or someone
over there and incorporate business
other otherwise you're just the same as
everyone else trying to MH trying to
recruit the us from the UK and like you
need us phone numbers and US bank
account and like it's a little bit more
complex than just right I'm going to
start pitching the US now so I think
that's good but I just say like you've
got to get someone over there get an
office over there even if it's just one
person um that's how I would do
it so let let's sort of segue into Joe
the business owner then I think why
don't we start with because I think I
shared with you this is something that's
come up more more and more with um
Founders that I spoke to over the last
couple of months it's something that we
spoke a lot about at our live podcast
event in London but you know you you
shared the you know the average Billings
for the people that had a Target was 400
Grand in in the last Financial year that
that that's really impressive so I felt
like what you shared with me yesterday
when we were prepared for this was I
wrote down you just really double down
on being unapologetically like what you
guys are you double down on this is a
sales job what's fundamental in our
culture is that we all do business
development and that's something that we
all want to commit to becoming really
great at um you know doubling down on
work ethic doubling down on putting in
the hours um and that's something that
you've really leaned into as and you
think you know is is one of the cool
things around the the net positive of
being you've grown your gross profit and
you've grown your Revenue whereas I
think a lot of people I know it's not
the entire year but it's a large chunk
of this year compared to last year but
most people I've You Know spoken to
describing last year probably not going
to get close to that this year is what a
lot of people said because of the way
that you describe the market a lot of
people experience that so just talk just
talk to us a bit about what that looks
like on a on a like just being
yourselves like what what does that look
like what were the things that you were
really driving what did that sound like
in your office what was you saying to
people because I think it'd be good you
know for you to share that and for
people to maybe take inspiration or or
hear that yeah definitely so there's I
mean there's loads I could talk about
with this but I guess
to for me like one of the key things is
leading from the front right and when
people were coming to me so our year
September to September so they're coming
to me in September saying life science
Market is dead like I'm not going to be
able to do anything in life science this
year and I thought right well I'm going
to have to do something about this so I
personally build
358k q1 in life sting so that was the
first thing I did was like right I'm
going to show everyone that the market
is possible to score fees in so what
what was your response though when you
have people saying I'm reading the news
I'm on LinkedIn it's got it's dead like
got these clients that said there like
what is your respon like how what is
your response that cuz people listen to
this they would have people saying Joe
like it's done mate like last year that
was it that was the best year in
recruitment it's not happening again
like what's your initial response when
someone says that to you yeah probably
three things I guess the first one is of
course it's hard that's why they're
paying you a 40K fee to do this
search point point two is it's not dead
this is just how it always was pre
pandemic and I truly believe that
recruitment's always been hard and any
job where you're making like 100k plus a
year of course it's hard so it's always
been hard and and I'll say it's not the
Market's not done it's just back to
normal and then fre I say well look at
my Billings I say I've 358k in q1 so
it's not Tad and again like people might
it sounds a bit arrogant to say but it's
it's reality and and it's not just me
it's the other directors as well who are
built who both buil over 500k this year
it's it's a real effort from everyone to
lead from the front and be like look I'm
showing you it's possible here it's it's
easy for me to sit there and say oh no
it's not this is how it always is it's
always hard or yeah they're going to pay
you a big fee but then if I'm not doing
it and proving it and leading from the
front and they're not hearing me on the
phone then then it's all it's just like
yeah well it's all well and good you
saying that but you're not doing this
it's easy for yeah and I don't ever
really want it to be that um
so so that's a big thing and then I
guess to go back to your question like
how did we double down on everything I
guess I kind of Sidetrack there um so we
launched accountability as a new value
which was big for us interesting um we
hi so how did you how did you launch
that like how did you like do you know
what I mean how was that communicated
cuz I I get why you'd be talking about
that guys need to [__] hold
yourselves accountable this is important
how did you communicate that to people
cuz not like that not like that
[Laughter]
no so we hired a head of HR earlier in
the year and and she's made us a a lot
more value LED as an organization and
and that's been massive for us because
you can relate everything back to it so
we did a half year presentation we do a
half year and end of year so at the
halfway point we're like look we've been
talking about accountability or yeah
we've we've said so you all you need to
get minimum of eight first stage
interviews and you need to hit minimum
of 15K per month but but now it's time
we we track that and we're calling it
accountability but I'm going to be
accountable and and it's a it's a shared
effort of accountability for us all to
hit our targets and order to grow the
company and all to be successful and hit
our promotions and launching
accountability has been really impactful
for us but you have to live it you have
to breathe it and you have to do that
every day and and I have to do it and it
has to come from the top so so that was
massive and then moving forward further
from there we had to make unpopular
decisions right so there was through Co
everyone wanted to work from home or had
to work from home and then when they
returned there was the whole hybrid
debate and and again like we were kind
of going with it because it was the easy
thing to do and we were we were doing a
bit flexy and then eventually it just
came the time where it's like look when
if you're not hitting your target
quarterly you're in the office full
time so hitting your target is in the
yeah you're not hitting your Revenue
Target which is which is again like is
everything for us we're still small
company um so if you're not hting
quality Target you're in the office and
we want you to be in the office and then
we've made a real effort to to promote
our top billers in the sense of like
look like you're working with an 800k
Bill set next to year there's a 600k
biller there's a 700k biller that you're
working with some of the best Recruiters
in the world here you should want to be
around them that's how you learn we if
you want to have an amazing year and
make life-changing money and hit
promotions like you need to be working
around the top 1% Recruiters in the
world and I'm confident we've got 10 15
people here who are like world class
recruiters who everyone could learn from
so we we were big on getting everyone
back in the office and
we at what point was that when did you
communicate that that
probably around January this year so
like q1 was a little slow for us um as I
think people are just into the market
and we were a bit behind where I thought
we were going to be and where we wanted
to be which was hence me doing my
Billings and then and then it was like
look things have we've got to get ahead
of this and we're going to double down
on hard work we're going to double down
on accountability we're going to double
down of being present in the office and
we're going to double down on BD and
sales and and it was like look you guys
are good on the candidate side you know
that but now I'm going to now me and the
directors and the other leaders in the
business we're going to meet you
worldclass sales people we going to meet
you worldclass Ed people and and we got
all of the top I think probably top 10
people in the company ran a training
session on different methods of BD and
how they do BD and um again that's a
reason for people to be in the office
and it's all well and good saying yeah
look be accountable but if they don't
know how to do it then there's no good
so we so we paired that with training
and um and we did some and there some
really really good sessions that people
delivered on on different on how they do
BD and everyone's a little different
right so um what I talked you through
earlier was my Approach but there's a
top B from last year he's heavy on
LinkedIn BD um so so I guess that's kind
of like how we doubled down on
everything after
q1 um you said um unpopular opinions how
did you deal with those then was it if
people said Joe that isn't what we said
when I interviewed here like I don't
want to be in the office I I want to you
know have more flexible time obviously
on a case-by casee basis but are you
just owning that and being like well
actually maybe this isn't the right
environment for you then like what how
did you how did you navigate those like
you said you said it's UNP you said it's
unpopular because it is you know on
LinkedIn right now yeah on LinkedIn
you're you're you know you start
spouting the in the office all the time
all of that I understand I understand
the cell and why people should be in um
but yeah you're going to have you know
loads of people saying Joe that's so old
school it's outdated all of that so how
how do you navigate that unpop opinion
yeah and I mean it's easier now right
cuz the track records there and the
numbers are there to back it up and it's
like well hang on we've just grown 27%
this year using this method so I
appreciate you saying that but like look
I mean I read an article recently where
I was talking about Market leading
recruitment companies struggling and
laying people off
and and we've been lucky we've we had
27% growth this year but that kind of
backs it up so it's easier now to say
well we've just had a really good year
doing this so we're not going to change
it but at the start we were owning it
and it was like look I appreciate that
but you've got a Target and you need to
hit it it's a sales job you start
hitting your sales numbers you start
smashing your sales numbers like we'll
talk about flexibility and remote and
work from home but until you're smashing
your numbers you you're in the office
and you're learning from the best and
and again not everyone wants to hear
that which is fine there's there's a
million work from home jobs now
um but what we're trying to get people
to build 400k yeah we're trying to get
them to change their life we're trying
to get them to make life-changing
commission and and it took us a bit of a
while to become Unapologetic about that
um but I feel like now we are and now
we're owning it and the people that are
here like it and they love it and we're
not miss selling this for anything that
it's not yeah no that's what I WR about
it I think that's that's where a lot of
fans I've spoken to had the challenge
with it cuz they sort of just panded to
what what their team wanted and then
it's ended up being you know they they
weren't happy with what they were seeing
and then they were wrestling with it
struggling with it so right now then if
I hit my target John I'm in metric
search are we getting flexi time or now
is that just gone now even if I hit my
target you if you're hit his Target
you're getting one you're getting one
day week work from home yeah the one day
man yeah do I gets pick to day yeah do I
gets Pi today you get Tuesday or
Wednesday Tuesday or Wednesday yeah
that's it but this is this is what I
mean right like you're not you're not
doing someone a favor if you're just
letting them work from home and they're
not hitting their numbers just cuz they
want to work from home and if the
business owner and the directors are
annoyed about it and you're just going
oh like how do I get them back in the
office like they're not hitting their
numbers like they're costing us
money like that's not that's not doing
them a favor is
it Le let's talk about because I know
this has been something that you've
invested time resources in and we
continue to be if you want to continue
to go on this growth trajectory talk to
us about your journey in you know
investing in the right infrastructure to
grow metric SE because I know that's
been a focal point for you so I know
when we're going through this the sort
of or chart that you shared with me like
you said I think you said what you've
got how many leaders was there seven got
17 leaders and we got six non
billers yeah so talk to us a bit about
maybe why don't you talk to us about
what was the like first non Billa or
like who did you like who did you want
to how did we want to start building
this side of the business which is
absolutely essential for you to scale
yeah um yeah it's interesting so this
was a big Focus for for R and when I did
I think I did a podcast last year around
November time I was like that a focus
for us this year is building this back
office um and that's been massive for us
and it's funny like when so we've hired
L &d we've hired HR we've hired
marketing uh We've hired a finance
director um Finance director is an
obvious one but Market have come in and
we like wow like how did we get this far
without having anyone in marketing and
same for L&D and same for HR and and
same for ta which which we've hid again
this year so they all come in and had an
amazing impact but but what we were
doing previously was like we had Tim who
was one of the directors who was just
doing everything he was doing Ops he was
doing HR he was doing ta he was doing
L&D and he was like doing a good decent
job in all of them and it was ticking
over and we did 10 mil in sales and we
were like yeah this is fine like we're
but then obviously to get from what 50
people to 100 people like you can't just
do that with with one guy doing that so
then we have made a real conscious
effort to get really good people into
all those roles this year um and we feel
really confident that's going to help us
get from the 12 and a half million we
did this year to to 15 million this year
and and Beyond so um they've all had
massive imp how do you see that side
growing then where else are you like in
invest investing which you deem to be
important to to keep going in the right
direction what what else is is really
key you thinking have to put more
resources into marketing yeah is it the
the HR side I don't know what is it yeah
marketing is a big one for us and and
part of the strategy for this year is
really pairing marketing and
sales and the fact that we've got this
far by just having pure BD people and
pure sales people and no real marketing
is is almost crazy so we're going to be
investing a lot in marketing um that's
I'm excited about that and I think
that's going to help a lot and then I
think the L&D and
upside again my goal is to have an L &d
person in every office so we can onboard
people consistently in smaller groups so
we've been doing groups of like eight at
a time and then fly in the L&D person
around the world to deliver training
whereas like we should just have four
people one in each office and you can
onboard people throughout the year in
smaller groups
um and it's and that's hard right and
that's part of the problem of being a a
Glo truly Global business with four
officers in like entering year five like
you don't have all these things to hand
straight away but we're working on it um
but that'll be that'll be a big one for
us this year and hopefully if we do this
again in 12 months time we'll be talking
and it'll be L &d and Ops people
everywhere so we'll see love it and then
talk to me about like you personally
like how you said you work 24/7 yeah
work life like you know as in like for
me
personally I I really don't like the
term work life balance personally um I
don't think it's helpful um I think you
know it's individual and it's you know
down to you to work out what works best
for you um if that's being on all the
time if that's making sure you switch
off and you're present with your partner
your kids or whatever um or whether
that's getting home doing what you need
to do and then you know working getting
in evening like it's individual I think
it's so unfair for people cuz I'm sure
you have it Joe people like [__] living
Joe's life he's working all the time
yeah like you work all the time Joe like
all that right and I think oh where's
the word life balance Joe it's you're so
out of whack like all this so how have
you like talk to me about yourself like
you managing all this cuz mate there's a
lot going on here yeah there's a lot I
mean I'm a bit weird in the sense right
that I wanted to go into recruitment
like I didn't fall into it and and a few
of my friends
they take the mck out of me and say like
you're probably the only person who like
actively applied for recruitment jobs
which is funny um but I wanted to do it
and I and I loved it and I and I still
love it now and I enjoy doing it like I
I like going to any of our
offices I like my job I like
interviewing people like I enjoy talking
to clients so for me like it is work but
but I don't know what I would be doing
well I mean I'm sure I'd be fine if I
wasn't doing it but like it it's a good
way for me to do stuff and I enjoy it
and it's not a huge problem for me and
like I guess I am switched on 247 and
thinking about work a lot of the time
but but for me it's worth it right I'm
30 like I'm building something me and
the other director feel like we're
building something really exciting here
I'm sure there'll be plenty of time for
me to be switched off and golfing when
I'm older um so like I'm comfortable
with it and I enjoy it and um helped us
get to this point so far right and I
don't know if we would have got as far
as we had if I wasn't so driven and move
what and again I probably don't spend as
much time as I should enjoying it in the
moment because I'm always thinking to
the next thing so like we had a great
year last year and I'm proud of that but
I am now it's that's in the past and
it's like right let's get California
open and Florida and let's get 15
million so um I guess that's it I mean
that's the way I choose to do it but
everyone as you you say everyone's
different right and not everyone's wired
the same so I guess youve just got to do
what works for
you like talk to me
about toughest day on this business
Journey so far like surely there's been
like a dark A Dark Day what's been has
there been a moment where he was like
[__] is this going to work what's going
to happen now um the co period was is
like
just probably by far the hardest thing
I've done because
I think we were like seven eight people
we just hired some new grads at the time
we just moved to a new office in New
York like we' launched in September 2019
and then literally four or five months
later it's like oh everyone's got to go
home and I've got rookie recruiters
working from home
and and I've just gone from being part
of char Morris to being like the
managing director of metric and I'm out
on my
own that was tough for sure that was a
difficult p how like so how did you deal
with that what was going through your
mind like surely you was doubting
yourself
um not really doubting myself to be
honest it was revert back to typ it's
like I've got to start billing here like
I've got to keep the lights on and I
again probably talking to every single
person I've ever spoke to in my career
and was like Hey look I've just set this
business up like it's co like please
tell me you're hiring for something and
I end up I end up filling loads of it
roles for Farmer companies weirdly and
uh and managed to build pretty well and
and again it was just I just got to get
my head down and do this now but but
again I always see opportunity in these
down markets and we hired some great
people through the pandemic because no
one was hiring grad so we got a couple
of great I think we got a couple of
experien recruiters and a couple of
rookies who who are still with us now
and have been great and they're like
part of the story and the whole Co
period And I guess same for every
business but the whole Co period is like
quite a big part of the metric DNA now
that we got through that in New York
like the probably the strictest lockdown
and the most expensive city in the world
and hardest place to run a business and
like we got through that four months old
so again if you can get through that we
can get through the life science Market
being a little bit tougher this year and
that's kind of toughened us up a bit I
think but that was that was hard um and
then I guess probably the period of this
year when it was q1 and we had a slow q1
and and it was like right hang on a
minute like the mark the market is
getting a bit tougher and we're not
going to just fly for our targets like
we did last year so so the year we did
10 million every single person in the
company had their best every year in
recruitment which is almost I don't know
it's probably say for a lot of
businesses but but that was like a real
high and then it to start getting
tougher was like oh right well we're
going to have to actually think about
things a little bit more here and be a
little bit more
calculated um but touch wood like that's
that's it really I don't think there's
been any other like
terrible days
um so again touch what I don't want to
jinx myself um like what I was going to
say um and then you're doing a bunch of
things that you haven't done before
hariring HR head of ta marketing so how
how are you navigating that are you you
know tapping into people you're getting
advice from are you just you know you
strike me as someone I'm I'm for me
personally my sort of default is taking
action and I feel like that's sort of
theme Here is like you see a problem or
you're hearing things it's like well I'm
just going to hack on and take action
but like how have you how have you
navigated that cuz you're doing a lot of
things for the first time yeah and and
you're right and and it is what you say
like I like I am a doer right like I
want doers in the business I had get
[__] done and that is I mean in terms of
HR like my wife's the HR Director so
like I that was that one's easy like I
just what for your business no no no I
wouldn't be surprised a lot of people
work with there no no I mean maybe one
day but um but no so I like ask she she
can help me with that so that one's a
pretty easy one but but I man I manage
them in a similarish way to we manage
recruiters like we manage we we'd be
really honest about our
expectations
um we we set them clear targets and like
and again a lot of this is just like
genuinely being supportive to them so so
marketing I guess and and ta like
they're good ones like we tell them what
we want we're supportive we're we're
good to them like and then a lot of for
me a lot of it's just about being a good
person and being authentic and me not
trying to pretend I know everything
right so like with the finance director
like I'm not going to start telling him
how to do the accounts or like how to
work stuff out and with Jaden marketing
I'm not like hang on like you get off
canva like let me have a go okay I just
say I don't know and like look this is
you this is your you run this department
we'll give you the autonomy to run it
like this is the vision um I I don't
stress too much about it if that makes
sense you're not trying to act like you
know all the answers no no and that's
what we hiring for right like we we're
hireing markeing so I don't I don't know
it and we hire HR because I I'm not HR
Director so um but it's fine and like
again I
don't I guess it's a bit of a weird one
like i' probably never struggled too
much with having like impostor syndrome
or worrying or being like Oh I don't
know what to do with with X or Y and as
we get bigger that might change and we
might get to 200 people and I'll be like
wow like this has outgrown me yeah but I
just never really felt that to to date
so it's a difficult one for me to give
you like a great answer in the sense of
like this is what this was my plan for
hiring marketing no yeah I was just
curious because I know sometimes people
struggle with that so but I think you've
answered it yeah don't try and assume
that you know more than you do you
you're hiring experts who are experts in
that role so you know you listen to them
you're going to be able to help them in
different ways so yeah like I I get that
um so look how do we just curious to get
your thoughts like you come back to
Nottingham You're Building you know a
business you have an office in
Nottingham like pretty mad that you know
you're in this position you're now could
be a great employer for local people in
Nottingham I think this is what I love
about recruitment like obviously sent
you my friend who I think could be great
in Recruitment and I was just like so
excited to tell him about it cuz when
people aren't aware of like a career
Recruitment and I think they'd be great
and you tell them like it's such a
[__] great industry like what a great
you know Journey that you're on and
you're now able to create amazing
opportunities for local people in your
local area where you grew up like unreal
I just think it's like yeah I love it as
well and that you I guess maybe you but
you're struggle to find anyone who loves
recruitment more than me but I think you
might you might beat me to that but no
like it's such a great job it's such a
great career and when we set up
Nottingham our goal is to be the best
company to work for in Nottingham and
and me and a couple of directors think
we already are I mean like there there's
not a ton going on here right but a job
in nottingam where you can make 100K a
year and you doing all the Barcelona
trips top Billa trips you can get a
Rolex for doing a million like that's
quite normal in New York and it's quite
normal in London but in Nottingham
there's not too much like that so we're
excited and um hopefully your mate who
you've recommended to us like i' if it'd
be great for him if he's good um and it'
be great for us if he's good so um but
no I I love the industry it's Chang my
life for sure um and I think a lot of
the people who work here are very
grateful for not just metric but also
just working in Recruitment and being
successful in it so um so yeah no I
agree feel really passionately about
that as
well love it well Joe look um amazing J
you've been on so far I'm really uh
interested to see how things you know
carry on evolving for you but been an
absolute pleasure mate so thank you yeah
thanks so much for having us um really
appreciate all your time so um yeah
thank you very
much